je sais pas c'est la bagarre un seul mec
les atouts c'est aller à l'onu
il est encore dedans tournez vous
monsieur montrez moi vos mains doucement
causé blessure c'est un crime dans notre
état monsieur reacher parce que les
menottes et au trot il ya deux choses
qui vont se passer dans les 90 secondes
demande pardon d'abord le téléphone qui
est là va sonner
ensuite ces menottes seront vos poignets
quand vous irez en prison la papa est
bâti deux ans voilà une prédiction qui
me laisse sans voix monsieur rituel il
va pas s'arrêter de sonner
merci de nous avoir prévenus quant à
washington j'aurais pas de bouger toutes
ses décorations vous êtes une légende on
se demande pourquoi vous avez raccroché
je me suis levé un matin un uniforme à
l'est plus jack reacher pour le majeur
turner le majeur turner a été arrêté on
l'accuse de quoi d'espionnage c'est un
coup monté
il en sait beaucoup ce rituel comment ça
va j'aime pas que vous suivent tu te
prends invincibles c'est ça c'est ça
et si je t'invite bras pour te massacrer
avec faudra pas dangereux voire ritchie
ils sont là pour vous éliminer
mes hommes ont été tués par l'un des
nôtres c'est plus gros que je
l'imaginais ça vous est déjà arrivé de
perdre avocat
vous croyez au dessus de la loire
mais je suis pas la loi alors vous
devriez vous mettre à courir parce que
je vais me mettre en chasse et quand je
vous trouverai je vous tuerai tous
c'est la coupe de cheveux vous avez tous
le même coiffeur
la crise
le maire
lucie aubrac
comment